- I am so excited to
try some Japanese candy.
- I am freaked out.
(upbeat slow techno music)
So these, koala things,
- Yes.
- Yay.
- They look like Hello Panda,
so they have to be good.
Oreo meets Milo in a koala-shaped pod.
- Kind of like an Oreo, but a lot softer.
- It reminds me of like tiramisu.
- Yeah.
- I could put away a whole
thing of that I reckon,
in one sitting.
- Why koala though?
That's interesting.
- Nebaa
- Is that a sepository?
- Yes.
- Yeah.
- I like it, it's like a challenge,
it's like how long til it goes away.
- This is your normal, run of the mill,
hard lolly you get on
the shelf in Woolworths.
- The guy with massive
biceps around his brain.
- It looks like a constipated brain.
One, two, three.
- Mmmm.
- Why?
- Tastes like fish food.
- Yeah.
- Tastes like what B.O. smells like.
- Like beef jerky, but jelly.
- Yeah, really salty.
- Very salty.
- I'm sorry Japan,
like I love everything else, but
- Look at this though,
this cute little butt here
you're just like aw,
I want to eat that butt, right?
- It's a personified butt and
he's the yolk.
- I hope it's a butt.
It's not a butt.
It's kind of got a Life
Saver initial flavor.
- Very citrusy.
- It's mango.
- It's mango right?
- I'm going with that.
- It's tropical punch, Just Juice poppers.
- Yes.
- Buttlollies number one.
- Buttlollies.
- This is the kind of lolly
that you have during summertime
or during winter to
remind you of summertime.
- So I'm hoping this is vegetarian.
- It looks like dried seaweed.
- Or skin.
- You had to say that
before I put it in my mouth.
- I'm sorry, is this candy?
- Aw the texture.
- See, you must be a texture person
cause that tastes really good.
- I don't know whether I'm having
meat or seaweed or dried skin.
- Like beef jerky seaweed.
- It tastes like salt.
- And paper.
- Paper salt.
- What's up you flavored KitKat?
This is my jam.
- I love wasabi.
I love KitKats,
so this should be delicious.
- Where's the wasabi dude?
Okay wait, there it is.
- Definitely taste the wasabi,
and it bloody works,
It's genius.
- I don't usually get the
green tea ice cream but
I could put away definitely a few of those
after some
(mumbles)
- Yeah, for sure.
- Japans candy kills it.
- Japan is the best, so.
- Obviously.
- I think that we're just not
used to some of the flavors
that Japanese kids would sort of love.
- This looks fancy.
It feels like it should
there be a ring in there.
Will you have a break with me?